hey there my little sugar buns my name
is Pierre and I've been doing gaming
videos for this channel for about two
years now it's time for something
different so I'm gonna stop the win that
and I want to focus on my real passion
and in life which is makeup and fashion
so um I want to start off by just doing
a regular makeup tutorial to to just
show my style what I do I hope I can
give you both some tips this is my face
without any makeup
I mean yuck right so I I start with this
umm it's clear and matte it's just to
make the skin oh people put this in your
face you want to get a good click and
just just start rubbing it in there you
may think I took a bit too much but
you're out of your mind yeah you want to
get it in there real good so now that we
have the right color in our skin hashtag
beautiful okay so the next thing I'll do
is I'll use this pumpkin mousse butter
on my cheek because I wanna i want that
cheek cheek filling I want my style to
be kind of like hey we can we can we can
we can have a glass of wine and talk
about our feelings but also have well
whale sex you never had real sex I think
that's that's good
good color next up is the lipstick it's
from Mac you can get these um unmatch I
mean you can get yeah and some people
some people think it's weird that boys
have make wear makeup and to that I say
you're just jealous of my fabulous
that's what I'd say are you doing
hashtag hi I think that's pretty
attractive
I don't know buy you bros so yeah I like
to finish with a mascara because it's
like the most difficult one I like to go
with an Egyptian style this some
sometimes I guess I changed my mind
actually it's not [ __ ]
don't panic if you go wrong with the
mascara um people probably not gonna
notice it anyway if I was a girl I would
be all over myself I'm gonna finish out
with this bad gal because that's what I
am so yeah if you don't have any makeup
you can just borrow from your mom it's
normal for boys so don't be shy if you
want to look fabulous you're gonna have
to go through a couple of sacrifices I
mean do you think I became this fab in
one day no took me years um so yeah that
was my makeup tutorial um feel feel free
to rate um on a scale how I did again
you know um I think I did a little
better than last time
I think it's pretty good you can see
I'll show you a little closer
are you doing alright so I want to
finish off this with an outfit that I
found yesterday and it's pretty damn
beautiful
Oh